when i cast my gaze on you know culture  and society at large right now it's as  if we're  suffocating on an atmosphere that is  completely compassion deprived as we  descend into our respective information  silos and virtue signal to the people  that we agree with we're able to show  compassion for those people and  completely handicapped when it comes to  expanding our ability to have empathy  for  somebody else's experience or somebody  else's point of view  and without  embracing more compassion into our own  personal lives and  with respect to the people that we  encounter how do we ever move forward as  a culture like it's a house of cards  that's going to collapse on top of  ourselves